in four years lizzie has built her curly
hair care business from kitchen table to
a two million pound a year concern
with customers in the uk and europe but
untangling the red tape of brexit
has been literally more trouble than
it's worth
devastating um
and it it's just really um i just wasn't
expecting to lose 15
of our business overnight since january
she stopped exporting to the eu
a decision that's cost her 000 pounds of
revenue
the way that we can continue there is we
can register the business there
but obviously the the money involved in
that
um would be huge we'd have to have an
office there we'd have to have a certain
number of staff to register a business
there it's just not something that we um
as a small company a small team would be
able to handle at the moment
lizzy's experience is shared by
thousands of businesses large and small
in january trade with the european union
plummeted
exports to the eu fell by 40.8 per cent
while imports declined by 28.8 percent
by comparison exports to the rest of the
world rose by 1.7
while imports decreased by 12.7 percent
the office for national statistics says
we should treat these figures with
caution not least because the lockdowns
that have closed high streets
and hollowed out city centers have
depressed demand
stockpiling ahead of brexit also played
a part and it may be
months before we know the permanent
impact
of brexit on trade
brexit minister lord frost said the drop
in trade was inevitable
and claimed freight volumes were back to
normal in february but his estimates
only account for the number of lorries
not what's in them
or the impact on the huge volume of
container freight
it all fed a gloomy economic picture
that saw gdp
fall 2.9 in january leaving the economy
still
nine percent smaller than pre pandemic
that it wasn't worse was down to
businesses like matthews adapting
we went to 100 delivery model that was
was great but we just couldn't cope
because it was really really really busy
um so it got me sort of thinking my god
how can we sort of maximize it
so i opened up another delivery kitchen
about a mile away
um and we sort of like were really
really busy there and then i opened up
another delivery kitchen
seven miles down the road as reopening
draws closer
businesses banking on consumers at home
rediscovering their appetite
and being able to reach those abroad
paul kelso sky news